Regent Street is London's ultra luxury
shopping Boulevard more than a million
people stroll by its shop windows every
week but right now there's something
extraordinary to be seen there these are
not window displays their sculptures
designed by architects the Regent Street
windows project is trying to bring
architecture and consumerism together
it's attracted creative people from all
over Europe like tempest Laura kia from
Switzerland who works for Puma I think
they starting to come up with something
much more sculptural an autumn redesign
it comes up with something that's
probably an eye-catching in a different
way much more about harrowing product
certainly what I see from all of these
and especially this one here is it much
more about the sculpture much more about
the overall form a couple of meters
further on is the atrium of the fashion
label as free these three women are
fascinated by the wooden waves the women
work for a Swedish fashion designer and
are hoping to get some inspiration I
like that you walk into it and you have
like you can nurse
eat on above you when you feel like
having an amelia is deafening to all the
different textures like sand and would
then yeah summer feeling that summer
feeling is exactly what Debra Nagin
wanted to evoke with her installation
more than 80 architects applied for the
shop window project only six were chosen
Deborah Nagin was awarded the contract
for the Esprit atrium it soon became
clear that she wanted to tell a story
the origin of the Esprit store came in
the late 60s when the founders were
traveling in California and hanging out
on the beach and they wanted a lifestyle
store that was really relaxed as relaxed
as that as the life they were living and
so we thought that if we could recreate
the beach in the shop it would give
people the sense of being at the seaside
and being in California and tell the
background story to spray it was an
appealing challenge for the London
architect who usually works on quite
different projects we went for scale we
knew that within the space they offered
us we could make something that went
from the ground floor of the shop right
the way up to the ceiling and and onto
the first floor the idea wasn't easy to
implement its closing time before the
start of the project the installation
has to be done before the shop opens for
business the next day the whole thing
will have to be put in place in one
night that's not usually in the job
description for architects
it's not what we normally do okay and we
couldn't really practice it either so
what we're doing now experimental they
will work over as regent street shuts
down for the night things are frantic
behind the shop windows being used for
the projects Antonia Faust is a member
of the famous Royal Institute of British
Architects she's come up with a fresh
idea normally with retail design you
might have a quite as traditional
mannequin with a backdrop and what
they're doing here is creating a new
space a new kind of reinvention of the
space that all exists it's a the brand's
to kind of refresh themselves and be
seen in a new light it also kind of
invigorates their own design teams and
allows them to kind of approach project
in a totally new way as well meanwhile
back at a spree it's 2 a.m. and there is
a problem Debra's calculations were too
tight the biggest wave doesn't fit in
the room her team manages to find a
solution but not everyone might think it
looks like a beach
it's okay and I'm not tired but I wish I
wish we've been able to it faster but
it's not possible to do this fast work
will go on for the next few hours at
least it's now 10 a.m. and time to open
for business the finishing touches are
put to the beach Debra Nagin can't wait
to find out what people think of her
installation
then actually very successful so far
we've got people coming in people that
wouldn't usually come in and just you
know have a look it does bring something
else to the high street it brings a
little bit of culture to the high street
rather than just shopping shopping
shopping culture and commerce a winning
combination